[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
brian laundry's personal items found in
a florida reserve and a medical examiner
on the scene the latest in the search
for brian laundry and i have to live
with this every day
and brings me nightmares and i can't
live with myself sometimes confessed
parkland school shooter nicholas cruz
pleads guilty to all charges plus a
settlement reached in the death of
elijah mclean while we know right now
about the federal civil rights lawsuit
and later the trial in ahmad arbury's
death to help the lawyers determine
whether or not
you can be a fair unbiased impartial
juror that is honestly seeking the truth
in this case we bring you to day three
of jury selection law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin we're following two big stories
out of florida as confessed parkland
school shooter nicholas cruz pleads
guilty on all charges but first new
information into the law and crime
network newsroom as brian laundry's
family lawyer says items belonging to
him have been found near florida reserve
this as the medical examiner is called
to the scene law on crime's angel levy
is here with the latest on the case
anjanette
brian the fbi says what appears to be
human remains was found in an area that
law enforcement had been searching and
those apparent human remains were
actually found near a notebook and a
backpack that belonged to brian laundry
and laundry's parents chris and roberta
had actually been out searching that
area on wednesday morning now laundry
has been a named a person of interest in
the death of his fiancee gabby petito
her remains were found in wyoming on
september 19th in the bridger teton
national forest the coroner said that
she was strangled to death now the
laundry's attorney steve bertolino tells
me chris and roberta laundry went to the
maya kahachi creek environmental park
this morning to search for brian the fp
fbi and northport police department were
informed last night of brian's parents
intentions and they met chris and
roberta there this morning after a brief
search off a trail that brian frequented
some articles belonging to brian were
found as of now law enforcement is
conducting a more thorough investigation
of that area and as i told you
the fbi says apparent human remains were
found there now brian laundry's parents
told police that they last saw him on
september 13th that was two days after
gabby petito was reported missing
laundry was charged you'll recall with
using a debit card that belonged to
gabby petito after she died without her
permission to date that's really the
only criminal charge that he faces he
and gabby petito you will recall were
seen on body camera footage during a
traffic stop on august 12th in moab utah
what initiated that traffic stop was a
man calling 9-1-1 and saying that he was
saw a man hitting a woman brian
thanks ange joining us today is uh terry
austin our co-host terry according to
the fbi the area where the items
belonging to laundry and these supposed
human remains was underwater until now
how will that complicate identifying the
remains
i think it's going to be very difficult
the water is obviously going to be
you know helping as far as the
decomposition of the body is concerned
so we're not going to have a body that
has more clues on it in terms of how the
passing occurred but right now brian
they don't even know whose remains these
are they're going to have to do a dna
test on it they're going to have to
determine whether or not this really is
ryan laundry they did find his backpack
in a notebook and apparently all of this
was near the car that belonged to the
laundries but at this point we don't
know whose remains these are they will
be identified and we do know as we heard
from angenette that the sarasota medical
examiner was there so we should find out
soon enough who this is yeah more
questions and hopefully answers soon to
come and jeannette has the potito family
said anything about this latest update
in the search for brian laundry
you know they've been very vocal uh very
measured in their comments but they have
not commented since this news broke
about these apparent human remains being
found in that area they wanted to and
were hoping to
find brian laundry alive they had said
in an interview broadcast earlier this
week that they wanted answers from him
so they may not get those answers now
should those remains be positively
identified as brian laundrys all right
thank you both we'll continue our
updates in this case as more and more
information comes up thank you again
on to capitol hill news now where eris
and reality star paris hilton turns
youth advocate calling for
accountability in congregate care
hilton's appearance in d.c marked the
formal entrance of the congregate
accountability care act into congress
the 40-year-old spoke as a survivor of
abuse against the troubled teen industry
as we've reported hilton says she
endured abuse as a teenager while she
was in the care of provo cannon school
in utah hilton claims that this abuse is
not uncommon and caused her years of
ptsd and trauma the bill is aimed at
creating a federal basic bill of rights
for youths as they enter the congregate
care this would include guaranteeing
contact with parents and guardians
education and access to the outdoors
still ahead on law and crime daily
confess parkland school shooter plead
guilty on all counts
means you are in there for the term of
your life and you do not come out until
you are no longer
[Music]
nicholas cruz will officially spend the
rest of his life behind bars and the
death penalty is still on the table just
ahead on law on crime daily's angela
levy explains what's next for the school
shooter
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galado gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily
nicholas cruz pleads guilty to killing
17 people in a shooting at a high school
in parkland florida back in 2018. this
comes if the families of the victims
settle a lawsuit with a school district
for 25 million dollars long crimes
angina levy is here with the change in
the plea and what one of the victim's
father says about it angenette
brian this plea means that this case
will now go straight to a jury that will
decide whether or not nicholas cruz gets
life in prison or the death penalty cruz
when changing his pleas his plea today
actually addressed the victims
i am doing this for you and i do not
care if you do not believe me and i love
you and i know you don't believe me
nicholas cruz explaining his decision to
plead guilty to the families of the 17
people he murdered at marjory stoneman
douglas high school it was valentine's
day 2018 when he killed 14 students and
three staff members
i am very sorry for what i did and i
have to live with it every day
and if i were to get a second chance i
would do everything my power to try to
help others cruz's words may have been
little consolation to the families left
to live with grief and loss every day
they sat in the gallery forced to relive
that day
how do you wish to plea guilty one by
one judge elizabeth shearer went through
the charges the prosecutor outlining the
facts of the case in excruciating detail
the defendant brought with him to
marjory stoneman douglas
11 firearm magazines a student walked
into the east stairwell and the
defendant said to him you better get out
of here something bad is about to happen
cruz had previously attended the school
he attacked he said he hates drugs and
believes the country would be better off
if people stopped smoking marijuana i
believe it's your decision to decide
where i go
whether i live or die not the juries
jamie gutenberg was one of the students
killed that day she was 14 and loved to
dance her father fred tweeted today the
murderer will plead guilty the news will
be about that we will focus on jamie's
life
fred gutenberg said that he is hosting a
fundraiser this weekend to honor jamie's
life it's a virtual dance-a-thon and the
money raised there will go to a
foundation that he and his wife open to
support causes that were important to
jaime the trial on the penalty phase
meanwhile will start on january 4th of
next year brian
thanks angeannette joining us today as
civil rights attorney jeffrey storms and
terry austin discuss the guilty plea in
the parkland shooting jeffrey no trial
straight to the penalty phase does
admitting guilt and foregoing a trial
help cruz's chances to avoid the death
penalty
on some level theoretically but i don't
know how much you know this strikes me
as one of the conversations that you
have with your clients where you
basically say give me something to work
with and that small something to work
with here is him showing some acceptance
of fault and accepting some
responsibility however i i think it's
unlikely that it's going to provide him
much help in the penalty phase of this
though it does give his lawyers at least
something to argue
absolutely
let's get right to that terry what did
you think of cruz's apologies uh to the
family's victims in your eyes was it
genuine
listen he pled guilty but i do not think
that apology was genuine he failed to
take full responsibility for his actions
he talked about drugs and television
that had nothing to do with his ruthless
actions he said that he has trouble
sleeping at night well how difficult
must it be for these families to sleep
at night and he also said that he wanted
the victims and their families to be the
ones to determine his fate the judge
made it very clear that it would be the
jury who is going to decide his fate and
the prosecution when
they recounted all of the actions it was
so evident to me that he is a
cold-blooded executioner he went back
and shot several of the individuals more
than once so if there's ever a death
penalty case this is the one
tend to agree there with that and
jeannette did the judge also sentenced
crews on the case where he is accused of
assaulting a corrections officer
he did brian or she did rather brian
judge shearer did
you might recall that last friday
nicholas cruz or last week nicholas cruz
pleaded guilty in that battery case well
today she sentenced him to 26 years in
prison for that that corrections officer
that he had assaulted
he did not want to appear in court but
said through a representative of the
prosecutor's office that he wanted cruz
to get the maximum sentence so he'll be
serving 26 years on that case
so a maximum on the assault of a
correction officer the sentencing
for that in the parkland school shooting
as engine had said still coming up on
january 4th one way or another he's
spending the rest of his life in jail
the question left for us all is whether
or not he'll get the death penalty of
course when that comes up law and crime
daily will be sure to be here to fill
you in with all the details thank you
everyone on to news out of chicago where
former empire actor jesse smallett's
criminal case will move forward after a
judge denies his dismissal request
smallet was indicted by a grand jury for
filing a false police report after
claiming he was attacked by men in ski
masks outside of his apartment he
reported that the two men attacked him
using racial and homophobic slurs after
investigating the two persons of
interest the police shifted their focus
to see if the actors staged the attack
on himself in order to promote his
career smallhouse attorney claimed that
his client's rights were being violated
since he had already performed his
community service and forfeited a ten
thousand dollar bond after a previous
deal to drop the charges the judge
denied this motion saying that the case
is now being led by a special prosecutor
and that he will not be jeopardizing
that arrangement smallet's trial is set
to begin in november of 2021.
coming up on law and crime daily jury
selection continues in georgia in the
trial for the death of ahmad arboring
collision mclean's family settles their
lawsuit against the city of aurora
colorado what the next steps are for the
family who tragically lost their son in
2019.
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back nearly two years after his
death elijah mclean's family announces a
tentative settlement agreement with the
city of aurora colorado
back in 2019 the 23 year old was stopped
by law enforcement while walking home
from a convenience store the officers
were responding to a caller who said
that they saw a man who looked quote
sketchy and was wearing a ski mask
mclean who was unarmed at the time was
wearing a ski mask because of a
condition that made him feel cold after
questioning him officers placed him in a
chokehold then mclean told them that he
couldn't breathe he was later handcuffed
and injected with ketamine by paramedics
after that he went into cardiac arrest
mclean died in the hospital three days
later attorneys for the mclean family
announced on monday that a settlement
agreement had been reached in a federal
civil rights lawsuit filed by mclean's
mother the suit alleged that the city of
aurora colorado the three police
officers two paramedics and the medical
director of aurora fire rescue violated
mclean's civil rights when he was put in
a chokehold and injected with ketamine
right now there are no specific details
about the settlements though it is
reported that mclean's parents will
determine where the proceeds will be
allocated
joining us today is civil rights
attorney jeffrey storms and terry austin
terry this is a great result for the
mclean family what do you think this
means for the family and the city of
aurora
well for the family brian nothing is
going to bring elijah back and it is
such a horrific case he's innocent
walking down the street literally
minding his own business and he is
basically attacked and held down and
then had this ketamine put into his
system and it was way too much and
clearly it caused his death i think the
settlement will help the family with the
pain and suffering that they are going
through and clearly they are going
through severe pain and suffering over
his death
the amount of the settlement has not
been announced as you mentioned and
that's probably because it's got to be
approved by the authorities we may hear
the amount after that authority has
basically approved it and as for the
allocation clearly we have to wait to
see what's going to happen some of it
will be allocated between the mother and
the father and so that has to be ironed
out and my thought ryan is that some of
this money like we've seen in other
civil rights settlements may actually go
back to the city to do some programs
absolutely jeffrey on a more macro level
do you think this settlement like the
floyd settlement you helped obtain is
furthering a momentum to better policing
especially concerning issues of mental
health
brian it's definitely one part of the
puzzle and as terry mentioned we don't
know what the amount is yet but i think
with respect to that piece of the puzzle
the settlement has to be significant
enough
that it makes administrators uh
politicians
understand that they need to enforce
training and they need to enforce
discipline to prevent this the other
piece of the puzzle that's really
critical are the criminal charges that
these individuals
because uh the criminal piece reminds
the officers that hey the city is not
going to just buy you out of this
your freedom your liberty is at
issue if you do not follow the law when
you're performing your job absolutely
just another piece of the puzzle as you
perfectly put there jeff we'll see how
those pieces fall into place as this
case progresses on update now on a story
we first brought you earlier in the week
the so-called january 6 committee votes
to hold former trump adviser steve
bannon in criminal contempt
on tuesday the committee unanimously
passed a criminal contempt report on
thursday the house will vote on a
contempt of congress resolution all this
is in relation to the capital riots that
happened on january 6th the house select
committee in charge of investigating the
january 6 attacks requested bannon
provided details about conversations he
had with former president donald trump
they say those conversations happened
leading up to the riots bannon refused
to provide the information and didn't
show up after being subpoenaed on monday
former president trump filed a lawsuit
to stop the january 6 committee from
obtaining his records
when we come back the latest in jury
selection for the death of a mont arbory
trial how many of the hundreds called to
serve will move on to the next round of
questions and what attorneys look for in
potential jurors next
welcome back jury selection stretches
into day three in georgia as a death of
a mod arbory trial is underway before
the trial can begin 12 jurors must be
seated along with four alternates jury
duty notices were mailed to a thousand
people in the brunswick georgia area
with 600 people called to appear
starting on monday all this as three
georgia men face charges of malice
murder felony murder and other related
charges in the death of 25 year old
ahmad arbury in february 2020 aubry was
shot and killed while jogging near his
brunswick georgia home he was unarmed at
the time of his death father and son duo
gregory and travis mcmichael tailed
aubry in a pickup truck before travis
mcmichael shot and killed him the pair
claimed self-defense and planned to cite
a georgia citizen's arrest law that has
since been repealed and replaced the
mcmichael's neighbor william bryan
followed along in his truck capturing
the entire incident on his cell phone
the shooting created national outrage
after the cell phone video went viral in
may of last year after that gregory and
travis mcmichael were arrested followed
by brian's arrest two weeks later all
three men have pled not guilty to the
charges on wednesday judge timothy
walmsley addressed potential jurors
first the state and then the defense in
this room are going to be asking you
what we call general
questions those general questions are
intended to help the lawyers determine
whether or not
you can be a fair unbiased impartial
juror that is honestly seeking the truth
in this case that effectively that you
will be able to listen to the evidence
presented in the superior court
and be able to make a decision reach a
verdict based upon the evidence
presented
jeffrey you represented the floyd family
and currently represent the parents of
dante wright what do you think the
aubrey family is going through right now
during jury selection
you know that now that we're a little
deeper into brian i think the family
starts to see what a grind this process
is initially you know for the first uh
initial jurors you're you're amped up
you're emotional it's setting in that
you know that some of these individuals
may be deciding one of the most
important things that's happened in your
lifetime uh and so
so you have that but then you just see
how long this takes and you know as that
process wears on the things that really
stand out to you or how frightening some
of these potential jurors really can be
and how relieved you are they're not on
your jury uh but at this point of time
i'm sure it's really wearing on the
family the length of the jury selection
yeah what i always tell my clients and
their families it's a marathon not a
sprint terry to that point jury
selection even for hustle lawyers seem
to be painfully slow why do you think
that is
i think there are a couple of reasons
first of all there are multiple
defendants here and each of them is
represented by an attorney and the judge
has allowed all of those attorneys to
have their own questions for the jury so
i think that is really adding to the
time they really should have
collaborated a little more and they
should have selected a lead counsel to
ask most of those questions even though
we know there's going to be separate
interests particularly as it relates to
william and he is not a mcmichael and he
was different he wasn't involved
directly he was taking the video and i
also think that you know there are
multiple people who've already heard
about this case so it's going to be hard
to find those who can be fair and
impartial absolutely and also the cross
administration we'd be like that as well
with each defendant thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you